we begin with breaking news from the uk
britain has approved the extradition of
wikileaks founder julian assange to the
united states that's where he's wanted
on 18 criminal charges including spying
washington says assange endangered lives
by releasing troves of classified
military records and diplomatic
correspondence assange called friday's
decision a dark day for press freedom
and british democracy he will appeal the
decision at london's high court and
tenacity in journalism well for more on
this breaking news story let's go to
london where our correspondent biggett
mars is standing by on the phone bigot
what more can you tell us
god i can tell you what the british home
secretary pretty patel has actually said
in her statement so she argues that
julian assange must be extra extradited
because the courts have basically
investigated his case and the courts
have investigated any human rights
considerations for example and they have
ruled that julian assange has to be
extradited and she as the home secretary
can only stop this extradition if
certain conditions are met for example
if we could potentially face the death
penalty and she has ruled that these
conditions are not in place and as such
that she must sign this expedition order
to the us
now what's likely to happen next
apparently assassin has already said
he's going to appeal
exactly so he has 14 days to appeal to
the uk high court and this is what
wikileaks
has said in the statement is going to
happen
they obviously must be quite devastated
because it it's probably getting uh the
air is getting thinner and thinner for
julian assange i mean he's already faced
a long battle inside the uk court and
has already appealed now the home
secretary has uh signed this latest um
extradition order and and it doesn't
look very likely that um that the
exhibition could be stopped however
they are going ahead and they will try
and they will fight until the very end
in order to
defend
who they say is somebody who's fighting
for press freedom and who has done
nothing wrong in their in their eyes
bigger master correspondent in london
thank you very much